the PlayStation 5 has had a solid two
years of releases but its upcoming slate
of exclusive games is beginning to thin
out a new leak may give us a first
Glimpse at the next wave of
announcements for the console as an
early gameplay video teases a new Sci-Fi
game the footage is an apparent tease
for a game in development for the PS5
utilizing Unreal Engine 5. industry
Insider dusk Gollum confirms the game to
be real as well as confirming that it is
the same as a project they have
previously posted about they nicknamed
ooze which supposedly refers to what
they claim to know about the game the
title is a reported collaboration
between internal PlayStation Studio xtev
a support developer and another external
European Studio while there's no
specific word on which external team
that might be an image pulled from the
leaked footage included the word red in
the HUD which hints towards people can
fly the developer behind outriders as a
slide presentation the studio created
mentions a project red in development
the footage shows a Sci-Fi RPG where a
character aims a gun at a massive
structure that appears to have tentacles
sticking out of it oozing tentacles the
footage has been archived and is unable
to be viewed as of this recording dusk
Golem stated in various responses to the
footage that he has seen much more of it
and this leaked footage is a much
earlier slice of the game than where it
currently is in development stating that
the title has been fully voice acted and
had music composed for it which yeah
would hinted the game much more ready to
be announced than what the footage
showed Xbox players don't think we've
forgotten about you you get some news
too as a treat namely that an Xbox
showcase is rumored for before the end
of January according to sources of
Windows Central Microsoft will host a
developer direct showcase on January
25th a live stream of game reveals and
updates similar to Nintendo's directs
and Sony's state-of-play events arcane's
upcoming Co-op vampire hunting game
redfall is said to be in the spotlight
while Minecraft Legends fought some
Motorsport and xenomax online Studios
content will also be featured all this
should come as music to the ears of
those who were disappointed by a lack of
a presence from Xbox at the game awards
however if you're hoping for some news
on Starfield it isn't time to celebrate
just yet bethesda's next RPG supposedly
won't be included in the first edition
of developer direct with the report
claiming that Starfield will instead be
the focus of a dedicated and bigger
showcase so far Microsoft has confirmed
that red 4 and Starfield will launch in
the first half of 2023 a game you don't
have to wait that long to play is dead
space remake which is launching in a
couple of weeks on January 27th however
if you pre-order the game now via steam
you'll receive a digital copy of the
original game's beloved sequel Dead
Space 2 a title many consider to be an
improvement over the original are you
excited at the idea if people can fly
potentially making a PS5 exclusive game
what would you like to see at Xbox's
developer direct let us know in the
comments and we'll see you here for more
Gamespot news
[Music]
foreign